ces plans de gestion c'est un ensemble
d'orientations qui qui dit par exemple
qu'il faut préserver les vues sur ce
paysage qu'il faut maîtriser l'étalement
urbain pour garder ces coupures entre
les entre les villages et à partir de
ces orientations chacun qui a une
responsabilité sur sur le territoire sur
l'aménagement du territoire doit
intégrer ces orientations dans les plans
locaux d'urbanisme dans les schémas
d'aménagement et ce terrain on est dans
un dans un village très caractéristique
que les guides 10 pittoresque qui n'a
pas de grands de grands monuments comme
villandry peut la voir avec son château
mais qui est très caractéristique par
son paysage par sa situation on est dans
un village qui est à proximité tour qui
est dans l'agglomération de tours sur le
plan administratif et donc qui subit une
pression urbaine donc un des enjeux
aussi c'est de gérer cette pression
urbaine